Bolivia and Chile are the 50 Cent and Kanye
West of Latin America.
Now, it is true, they share a border.
But other than that, they couldn’t be more
different.
Bolivia is one of the poorest countries on
the whole continent, while Chile is among
the wealthiest.
Bolivia is a paragon of the so-called indigenous
socialism, while Chile is known as the Mordor
of neo-liberalism.
And as if this was not enough, the two countries
are involved in seemingly never-ending territorial
disputes with each.
Nonetheless, now, there is one thing this
two countries have in common.
Yes, dear viewer... we are talking about WHITE
GOLD.
Wait…
no, I’m not talking about that sort of white
gold.
I’m talking about LITHIUM.
Lithium is the metal used for manufacturing
the batteries that power your cell phone,
your laptop and those electric cars that,
eventually, might flood our roads and highways.
They call it “the new oil.”
It’s the lightest metal on the periodic
table.
It’s value has been multiplied by 10 in
the last two decades alone.
And it’s demand doesn’t stop growing.
Between 60 and 80% of the world’s known
reserves are in an area called the LITHIUM
TRIANGLE.
This is an area that covers parts of Argentina,
Bolivia and Chile.
In these countries, lithium is abundant and
easy to extract.
In other words, this part of the planet might
soon become the new Saudi Arabia.
Among those three countries, Bolivia is the
luckiest one.
The so-called SALAR DE UYUNI holds 2 or 3
times more lithium reserves than the mines
in Argentina or Chile.
On the other hand, Chile already has a world
class mining industry.
However, despite these reserves Bolivia is
exporting less lithium than the other two
countries.
And Chile might actually soon be out of this
new “white gold rush”.
In fact, Argentina is the nation that is getting
the most attention from international investors.
So today’s question has to be...
What’s going on in Bolivia?
Why is no one exploiting their lithium resources?
And why is Chile following suit?
Today, we are going to answer all of those
questions.
But before… let’s take a look at the history.
A NEW POTOSI?
If you’ve been subscribed to VisualPolitik
for a long time, you already know that having
natural resources doesn’t mean you are rich.
Bolivia is a clear example of this.
This country has all the natural wealth you
can imagine: lithium, silver, natural gas…
Nevertheless, this is one of the poorest countries
in all of South America.
The silver mines of Potosi were the site of
war for the Spanish crown during the 16th
and 17th centuries.
In fact, Spaniards still say ‘this is worth
a “POTOSI”’ meaning that something is
too expensive...
But the native Bolivians didn’t reap the
benefits of that silver wealth and millions
died under the extreme working conditions.
This is why it is understandable that the
Government of Evo Morales is so reluctant
to allow foreign companies to get into the
country and extract the lithium.
Besides, let’s be honest… the real business
here is not in the raw materials but in the
industry that comes afterwards.
For a better understanding of this, while
we make this video, a metric ton of lithium
costs around $9,000 on the international market.
But if we take that raw lithium and we turn
it into batteries for mobile phones, we can
turn that lithium into a value of somewhere
between $1.5M and $5M.
Of course, this is just a rough estimated
and there lots of things that should be considered
here.
But it can help to look at a comparison.
Indeed it can explain this sort of news:
‘President Evo Morales opened, in 2013,
the first plant of lithium carbonate and,
in February 2014, the first factory of ion-lithium
batteries manufacturing.
But that is not all...
In Bolivia, Lithium is nationalized.
This means that, if you are a private mining
company and you want to work on Bolivian soil,
you must partner with the government and start
a new company which will be owned, partly,
by the government.
This new company can get paid for their service
of building the mine, setting up the machinery,
extracting the lithium etc…
BUT the lithium they extract belongs to the
government - they have no right to sell it.
So, now you might be wondering…
Why does Bolivia need foreign companies to
exploit their own wealth?
Can’t they do it themselves?
Well, the answer is NO.
Modern-day mining has nothing to do with the
image you probably have in your mind of a
guy with a hard hat and a pick ax.
Today mining requires high-end machinery and
world-class engineers.
As you can imagine, these things are scarce
in a country as poor as Bolivia.
If you wanted to create a competitive mining
industry in that country, without outside
help, you’d need decades.
This is why it is so important to utilize
companies who have the technology, the tools,
and the staff to do the job.
And this is why even Morales himself, unfriendly
to multinationals as he is, had to get out
there and find investors.
‘As soon as we have a big lithium industry,
Bolivia will set the lithium price for the
whole World’
‘I want to say to you, governments and private
companies, now you can join us’
OK, so what exactly is the problem here?
Well… as we said before, Bolivian lithium
is owned by the state.
This means that those companies who might
invest in the country, can only get a profit
from partnering with the government.
And from that profit, they must pay a special
mining tax that goes up to 37.5%, which is,
by far, the largest in the region…
And if this was not enough, according to the
World Bank, Bolivia ranks among the 50 countries
where it’s hardest to do business.
They rank at about the same level as Sierra
Leone...
Now, let’s say that you wanted to invest
in lithium!
Fancy investing in Bolivia, or maybe you might
prefer one of those other countries.
Maybe.
This explains why, at this moment, Bolivia,
while it is the country with the biggest lithium
resources, it is also the country that is
exploiting them the least.
If you pay attention to the chart here, you
will see that today, the leader of the lithium
race is AUSTRALIA.
This is surprising because the resources of
this country are 4 times smaller than those
of Bolivia.
Plus, Australian salaries are six times higher
than Bolivian ones.
So, as you can see, this is not a matter of
low paid jobs or natural wealth- but, simply,
good and bad economic policies.
But hold on a minute, because this is not
the only problem...
Don’t forget that Evo Morales’s dream
for Bolivia is that it becomes a manufacturing
leader in the lithium battery industry.
But…
well…
how exactly can they achieve this without
foreign companies setting up inside the country?
Alright, alright, yes, the government can
set up its own factory.
Great!
But technology, patents and the skills needed
are held by companies like Panasonic, Samsung
or Tesla.
Without these, Bolivia would need decades
of research in order to be competitive on
the international market.
Alright, so we mentioned Chile earlier…
Well, what’s going on over there?
CHILE FOLLOWS IN THE STEPS OF BOLIVIA
For years, Chile has been known as something
of a free market Disneyland.
More precisly, their mining industry was one
of the freest in the entire world.
We are talking about a country where the economy
relies heavily on copper mining.
This is why, in the year 1981, PINOCHET’s
dictatorship passed the so-called MINING LAW,
that allowed private businesses to own the
100% of a mine.
As you can imagine, this law kick-started
foreign investment in the country.
Suddenly, lots of companies like the Australian
BHP BILLINGTON or the Swiss XTRATA came to
Chile.
And yes…
I know what you are thinking…
all of these multinational corporations looted
the country and left it in poverty, right?
Right?
Well… you’re actually wrong.
Of course, these Canadian, Swiss and Australian
companies came to extract the copper.
But they also helped to finance lots of brand
new companies which employed Chilean workers
and were headquartered in SANTIAGO.
Companies like MINERA ESCONDIDA or ANTOFAGASTA
MINING.
In fact, thanks to this wave of investors,
Chile now has a world-class mining industry.
Actually, many of the engineers that are now
needed in Bolivia, live in the best neighbourhoods
of Santiago.
And this means that, Chile has been in a great
position to lead the white gold rush.
Nonetheless, in 2016, Chilean President, Michelle
Bachelet, declared that lithium was a different
animal.
‘We confirm the strategic condition of lithium,
which is property of all the Chilean people
and we will keep its state of non-concessible
material’
–Michelle Bachelet
In other words, the government of Chile is
following suit with Bolivia.
But with a difference.
In this case, the country already has the
technology and the staff to exploit its mineral
wealth in an efficient way.
Of course, many of those companies who were
willing to invest in the country have lost
all the interest.
But Chile has its own companies so it’s
not that much of a big deal.
Besides, until 2014, the other countries of
this Lithium TRIANGLE, Argentina and Bolivia,
were way worse places for investment.
So… this is sort of a “in the land of
the blind, the one-eyed person is king”
situation…
Until now.
Argentina has been the big surprise here.
While Chile and Bolivia have nationalized
their lithium and have tried, badly, to scare
away foreign companies, Argentina, with MAURICIO
MACRI (MAU RITHIO MAKRI) as its president
is doing something rather different…
And they are now getting all the attention
from international investors.
But we’re going to talk about that in upcoming
weeks, in a sort of second-part to this video.
So if you don’t want to miss that, please
do be sure to subscribe to this channel!
In the meantime, we have question for you…
Do you think both Bolivia and Chile can reap
the benefits of their lithium with these kind
of policies?
Or maybe Argentina will overshadow them?
You can leave me your answer on the comments
section below.
And, just before we go today, we’ve got
an important request from you!
You might have noticed that we rather like
using rock music in our videos, and we’d
love to hear from anyone who has a band and
thinks their music could be a good fit for
us!
We will of course give credit to any music
that we do use in a video!
If you are interested?
Please drop us an email at INFO@VISUALPOLITIK.NET.
Also, don't forget to visit RECONSIDER MEDIA
podcast.
They provided the vocals in this episode that
are not mine.
And if you liked this video, give us a thumbs
up and… as always, I see you next time.